Y esta es la respuesta:
la respuesta es la tecnología.
Ya sé, ya sé...
sí, sí, tecnología, la automatización jode a la gente, bla, bla;
no me refiero a eso.
No hablo del tipo de tecnología
que ha permeado nuestras vidas, y de la que la gente va a TED a oír.
No hablo de la tecnología de las cosas,
por muy fundamental que sea.
Hablo de otra tecnología,
de la tecnología de las ideas.
La llamo "tecnología de las ideas"...
qué perspicaz de mi parte.
(Risas)
Además de crear cosas, la ciencia crea ideas.
La ciencia crea formas de comprensión,
y en las ciencias sociales,
las formas de comprensión que se van creando
son las formas de entendernos a nosotros mismos.
Y tienen una enorme influencia en cómo pensamos,
a lo que aspiramos y cómo actuamos.
Si creen que su pobreza es la voluntad de Dios, rezarán.
Si creen que su pobreza es resultado de su propia incompetencia,
caerán en desesperación.
Si creen que su pobreza es resultado de la opresión y la dominación,
se levantarán en revolución.
Que su respuesta a la pobreza sea resignación o revolución,
depende de su entendimiento de las causas de su pobreza.
Este es el rol que juegan las ideas en formarnos como seres humanos
y por eso la tecnología de las ideas quizá sea
la tecnología cabalmente más importante que la ciencia nos da.
Hay algo especial en la tecnología de las ideas
que la diferencia de la tecnología de las cosas.
Con las cosas, si la tecnología es mala,
entonces sólo desaparece, ¿cierto?
La mala tecnología desaparece.
Con las ideas...
las falsas ideas acerca de los seres humanos no desaparecerán
si la gente cree que son ciertas.
Porque si la gente cree que son ciertas,
crean formas de vida e instituciones
que son consistentes con estas mismas falsas ideas.
Es así como la Revolución Industrial creó un sistema de fabricación
del que en realidad nada se puede sacar de la jornada,
excepto la paga al final del día.
Porque el padre, uno de los padres,
de la Revolución Industrial, Adam Smith,
estaba convencido de que los seres humanos son por naturaleza flojos,
y que no harían nada a menos que hicieras que valiera la pena,
y la forma de hacer algo que valiera la pena
era los incentivos, darles recompensas.
Esa era la única razón por la que alguien haría algo.
Así que creamos un sistema de fabricación
consistente con esa falsa visión de la naturaleza humana.
Pero una vez que este sistema de producción estaba establecido,
no había en realidad ninguna otra forma de operación,
excepto una que era consistente con la visión de Adam Smith.
Así, el ejemplo del trabajo es meramente un ejemplo
de cómo las falsas ideas pueden crear una circunstancia
que acaba convirtiéndose en verdad.
No es verdad,
que "ya no puedan conseguir buena ayuda".
Es verdad,
que "ya no puedan conseguir buena ayuda",
cuando le dan a la gente trabajo que es degradante y desalentador.
Resulta bastante curioso que Adam Smith
--el mismo tipo que nos dio este increíble invento
de la producción en masa y la división del trabajo--
entendía esto.
Decía de la gente que trabajaba en las líneas de ensamble,
de quienes trabajaban en las líneas, decía,
"En general se vuelven tan estúpidos como un ser humano lo puede ser".
Noten aquí que la palabra es "vuelven".
Con toda intención o no, lo que Adam Smith decía con eso
es que la forma misma de la institución donde trabaja la gente,
crea gente que se adapta a las demandas de esa institución
y las priva de la oportunidad
de lograr el tipo de satisfacciones del trabajo que damos por hecho.
La cuestión acerca de la ciencia, de las ciencias naturales,
es que podemos volcarnos en teorías fantásticas sobre el cosmos
con la plena confianza
de que el cosmos es completamente indiferente a nuestras teorías.
Funcionará de la misma maldita manera
no importa qué teorías tengamos del cosmos.
Pero sí deben preocuparnos las teorías que tenemos sobre la naturaleza humana
porque la naturaleza humana cambiará según las teorías que tengamos,
que diseñemos para explicar y entender a los seres humanos.
El distinguido antropólogo Clifford Geertz, dijo hace unos años,
que los seres humanos son los "animales sin terminar".
Con eso quiso decir que es sólo natural del humano
tener naturaleza humana,
que es por mucho producto de la sociedad donde vive la gente.
Esa naturaleza humana, es decir nuestra naturaleza humana,
es más creación que descubrimiento.
Diseñamos naturaleza humana
al diseñar instituciones donde la gente habita y trabaja.
Entonces Uds. gente
--son por mucho lo más cercano a lo que estaré de los amos del universo--
Uds. gente deben preguntarse,
cuando regresen a dirigir sus organizaciones,
¿sencillamente qué tipo de naturaleza humana quieren contribuir a diseñar?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)